temps et blessé une information du site
les jours votre réaction au fait que
vive indiqué bénéficie du chômage
partiel notamment pour sa filiale canal+
aux commandes c'est dividendes ou est ce
que pour vous c'est une situation
acceptable
oui j'ai cru comprendre qu'il s'agissait
d'une augmentation de 20 pour cent pour
cent
c'est tout à fait scandaleux c'est
extrêmement choquant et d'ailleurs
chacun en avait convenu puisque ils
avaient été demandés y compris
j'irai par des membres du gouvernement
que j'irai les entreprises qui
bénéficient des aides de l'état et en
particulier pour le dispositif du
chômage partiel ne distribuent pas de
dividendes à leurs actionnaires et on
voit que malgré cette affirmation qui
presque là pour amuser la galerie
semble-t-il tirait aucun dispositif
véritablement contraignant n'est adoptée
en la matière donc en effet c'est
extrêmement choquant et nous dénonçons
tout à fait c'est pratique et nous
demandons que des dispositions opérante
soient mises en oeuvre pour les
interviews